und jetzt das heute journal
mit 1 wolf und marietta slomka für die
deutsche nationalmannschaft lief es ja
heute bestens gelingt ihr mit wochen
noch ein sieg wäre sie sicher weiter
derweil befasst sich die uefa bereits
mit der endspiel frage und übte druck
auf die britischen behörden aus laut
britischen medienberichten haben die
fußball-funktionäre wohl sorge deswegen
corona schutzmaßnahmen nicht genügend
wie es in den londoner logenplatz nehmen
dürfen
andere haben andere sorgen wenn das mit
der delta variante richtig schief laufen
sollte könnte dieser sommer kurz werden
jedenfalls was die korona freiheiten
angeht und nicht nur in fußballstadien
dominique löschmeister berichtet das
wembley stadion in london unter anderem
werden hier die beiden halbfinalspiele
sowie das finale der em ausgetragen
obwohl sich in großbritannien die delta
variante immer mehr ausbreitet verlangt
die uefa
ausnahmen von den quarantäne regeln für
2500 vips vor allem sponsoren und
funktionäre der premierminister in der
zwickmühle
wir werden mit der uefa darüber sprechen
was sie wollen und sehen ob wir
vernünftige vorkehrungen treffen könnt
aber die priorität muss natürlich die
öffentliche gesundheit sein als die
poppig um vip gäste von der englischen
bevölkerung abzuschotten habe die uefa
ein strenges test konzept entwickelt
heißt es doch reicht das der spd
gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach ist
skeptisch das verhalten der uefa ist
hier verantwortungslos weil wir wissen
dass die data variante extrem
gefährliches ideen sich insbesondere in
england aus es muss alles getan werden
um diese ausdehnung zu unterbinden
hinter den kulissen droht die uefa
offenbar damit die finalspiele in
budapest stattfinden zu lassen hier gibt
es keine einschränkungen kein abstand
genau das aber sieht die bundeskanzlerin
kritisch es ist schön dass jetzt in
münchen zum beispiel wieder 14.000
fans sein können aber wenn ich
vollkommen besetzte stadien sehe in
anderen ländern europas oder will ich
ein bisschen skeptisch ob das jetzt
schon die richtige antwort auf die
augenblickliche situation ist ein volles
stadion wie heute beim spiel ungarn
gegen frankreich in budapest fraglich ob
das eine gute außenwirkung für ein em
finale in der pandemie ist
großbritannien jedenfalls verhandelt mit
der uefa damit wembley im spiel bleibt
ganz kroner korrekt hat die linke heute
ihren parteitag begonnen
am sonntag will sie ihr wahlprogramm
beschließen am veranstaltungsort waren
nur wenige die meisten delegierten
online zugeschaltet das macht es den
choreografen eines solchen parteitags
natürlich nicht einfacher für gute
stimmung und gemeinschaftsgefühl zu
sorgen
dabei könnte die partei von beiden noch
eine ganze menge für ihren wahlkampf
gebrauchen die letzten ergebnisse bei
landtagswahlen und bundesweite umfragen
sind für sie eher frustrierend und es
gibt mal wieder harten innerparteilichen
streckt volle woche berichtet 99 tage
vor der bundestagswahl will sich die
partei die linke ein neues wahlprogramm
geben
inhaltlich geht es um mehr mindestlohn
eine vermögensabgabe um mehr rente
dazu hat sich die parteiführung corona
bedingten diese hallen im südosten
berlins zurückgezogen streng
abgeschottet der rest der delegierten
nimmt online teil im saal der den
resopal scham eine abiturprüfung zu
pandemie zeiten versprüht kämpft die
linke mit sich selbst mit ihrer
zerrissenheit mit ihren gräben
entsprechend arbeitet sich die
ko-vorsitzende an den klüften ab ich
spüre natürlich auch den ärger und die
wut darüber dass wir auch in den eigenen
reihen diskutieren nicht immer auf eine
sehr produktive art und weise und ich
spüre natürlich auch das ist eine
gewisse angst oder furcht gibt das wäre
das alles nicht schaffen
die linke kommt dem zdf politbarometer
seit monaten nicht über sieben prozent
hinaus gefährlich nah an der
fünf-prozent-hürde
daher die angst
wir hier nicht zu guten und wir werden
es nicht tun weil wir zusammenhalten
weil wir geschlossen sind weil wir den
weg nach vorn gehen
und weil wir tatsächlich eine aufgabe in
dieser gesellschaft haben wir sind die
partei die linke
wir sind im klassenkampf bisher ist es
dem neuen führungsduo weder gelungen die
partei zu befrieden noch erfolgreich
waren zu bestreiten
in den letzten landtagswahlen bis auf
thüringen liefen für uns im osten
allesamt schlecht in sachsen anhalt
sachsen und brandenburg bekommen wir nur
noch zehn prozent der stimmen das
problem heißt kapitalismus dieser kann
mit rollator nur als ressource verstehen
die bundesregierung folgt mit ihrer
politik eindeutig den interessen des
kapitals wir als sozialistinnen wollen
dieses primat der wirtschaft über die
demokratie beenden und den kapitalismus
auf den müllhaufen der geschichte
schmeißen wir müssen regieren und das
ist ja appell an uns alle im wahlkampf
das müssen die leute spiegeln das muss
die parteispitze nach vorne bringen die
linke steht fürs regieren lasst uns
aufhören das gegeneinander zu
diskutieren
rassismus und die soziale frage sind
keine gegensätze sondern beides ist in
den mittelpunkt zu stellen
es war heute kein einfacher tag für die
linke
es war sehr heiß im saal die technik
klemmte immer wieder und der ein oder
andere delegierte verschwand
buchstäblich vom bildschirm wohl des
wetters bruder des fußballs wegen morgen
soll das programm endgültig beschlossen
werden
und dann schauen wir noch ins ausland
den iran wurde heute gewählt
präsidentschaftswahl
der sieger stand schon vorher fest
ebrach easy ein hardliner ganz im sinne
der konservativen geistlichen führung
des landes er wird den bisherigen
amtsinhaber anni ablösen der nach zwei
amtszeiten nicht mehr antreten konnte
juni galt ja als vergleichsweise moderat
soweit dieses adjektiv auf iranische
spitzenpolitiker anwendbar ist eine
echte alternative hatte die bevölkerung
bei dieser wahl nicht mehr protestieren
wollte blieb zu hause
und das taten dann auch sehr viele
iraner berichtet unser korrespondent
jörg brase
die einen jubeln die anderen zeigen dem
wahlsieger die kalte schulter
die siegesfeier in der hauptstadt wirkt
ähnlich inszeniert wie die ganze wahl
ihr kandidat hat gewonnen wie erwartet
für rossis anhänger ist es ein sieg
gegen alle widerstände von innen und von
außen
die leute sind trotz aller probleme
wählen gegangen trotz des corona virus
und trotz der propaganda des auslands
und seiner medien
die wollten die leute vom lernen ab
bringen aber mit der hilfe gottes haben
die leute gewählt und haben ein zeichen
schon am vormittag bekommt wahlsieger
reise besucht es noch amtierenden
präsidenten hassan rooney gratuliert
verspricht einen geordneten übergang
sie bedankt sich für das vertrauen der
wähler ich bin ein diener des volkes und
ich hoffe dass ich den erwartungen im
laufe meiner amtszeit gerecht werden
kann
auf jeden fall will ich auch die
erfahrungen der bisherigen regierung
irans innenminister verkündet am
nachmittag nicht nur den haushohen sieg
kreises sondern auch eine historisch
niedrige wahlbeteiligung
die gesamtzahl der abgegebenen stimmen
beträgt 28 millionen 933.000 4
das entspricht einer wahlbeteiligung von
48,8 zweitstärkste kraft hinter dem
wahlsieger man glaubt es kaum sind die
ungültigen stimmen 3,7 millionen
verweigerten sich in der wahlkabine und
übten dort eine andere form des protests
es ist richtig der widerstand gegen das
regime ist ständig angewachsen
er hat bei dieser wahl einen neuen
höhepunkt erreicht der 42 jährigen
geschichte der islamischen republik im
ergebnis war die wahlbeteiligung extrem
niedrig
auch am tag danach sind viele wütend
über eine abstimmung bei der sie im
grunde keine wahl hatten
das ist alles ein falsches spiel es war
vorher klar dass riesige welt wird das
hätte ihn jeder sagen können die vier
anderen kandidaten waren nur damit man
dieses theater spielen konnte jubeln
rossis anhänger heute einen präsidenten
dem die absolute mehrheit die stimme
verweigerte dann schalten wir noch nach
teheran zu unserem korrespondenten jörg
brase york ein neuer präsident der als
hardliner gilt wird das auch auf die
aussenpolitik auf die politik gegenüber
dem westen einfluss haben also
eigentlich nicht vermuten hier viele
denn die außenpolitik die macht ja
eigentlich nicht der präsident und auch
nicht der außenminister sondern die
außenpolitik die macht auch der
religiöse und politische führer des
landes ayatollah khamenei der trifft die
letzten entscheidungen und insofern kann
man davon ausgehen dass raí sie den kurs
fortsetzen würde letztlich auch die roan
die regierung gefahren ist das eine
aussöhnung mit den usa ist kaum denkbar
genauso wenig mit israel
das wird vielleicht sogar noch härter
werden und auch was das verhältnis zu
europa angeht was ja in der letzten zeit
schon sehr gelitten hatte auch da kann
man befürchten dass sich das land weiter
entfernt von europa und sich
wahrscheinlich eher china noch zu wenden
wird gilt dieser ja ich sag mal
pessimismus den hinter zum ausdruck
bringt auch mit blick auf das atom
abkommen was ja eigentlich reanimiert
werden soll
also ich glaube dass die hardliner zu
den cia auch zählt was das atom abkommen
angeht doch sehr pragmatisch sintra sie
hat ja angekündigt im wahlkampf bereits
dass er sich an das abkommen gebunden
fühlt und alle rechnen eigentlich damit
dass auch mit einem gewählten
präsidenten risi die verhandlungen die
im moment laufen zwischen den
unterhändlern irans und der vereinigten
staaten
doch zum erfolg kommen werden denn auch
sie möchte dass die us
wirtschaftssanktionen zumindest
teilweise aufgehoben werden wenn er
seine wahlversprechen auch nur
ansatzweise erfüllen will
dann müssen die sanktionen aufgehoben
wäre
man muss iran wieder mit öl handeln und
finanz transaktionen durchführen können
denn das land braucht neues geld in der
tat dankeschön jörg für diese
einschätzungen direkt aus teheran
und jetzt hans wolf den nachrichten die
bundesregierung will nach
zdf-informationen jetzt doch darauf
verzichten
bei neubauten ein solardach zur pflicht
zu machen
diese vorschrift sollte eigentlich habe
übernächsten jahr eingeführt werden nach
beratungen in den zuständigen
ministerien über das klimaschutzprogramm
ist das thema aber jetzt vom tisch
das kabinett will das gesamtpaket am
mittwoch beschließen
in den usa wird heute june teams der tag
der sklavenbefreiung zum ersten mal als
nationalfeiertag begangen
juni teams wird seit dem 19 juni 1865
gefeiert als auch in texas das ende der
sklaverei verkündet wurde
der kongress hatte den tag erst
kurzfristig zum feiertag erklärt
das allein mahnen einige aktivisten
bereiche jedoch nicht um den anhaltenden
rassismus im land zu beenden
bei der fußball europameisterschaft ist
die deutsche mannschaft bei ihrem
zweiten spiel in münchen als sieger vom
platz gegangen gegen auto galt mit 4 zu
2 robin cousins ist mit zwei vorlagen
und einem tor die prägende figur in
einem spektakulären spiel die deutsche
auswahl von beginn an dominant doch
portugal kontert oder zielt das 1 0
nach der führung durch cristiano ronaldo
minute 15
der verdiente ausgleich goossens mit
hereingabe und dias mit eigentor in der
35 minute kurz danach geht wieder ein
klärungsversuch nach hinten losgehen mit
dem zweiten eigentor der portugiesen
nach dem kimmig den ball aufgelegt hatte
kurz nach der pause wieder großes und
dann kam es zum 31
nach einer stunde krönte seine starke
leistung mit diesem tor zum 4 2 1 die
spielfreudige deutsche elf kassiert dann
noch ein gegentor 4 zu 2
der ärger nur von kurzer dauer denn
durch den erfolg an dem großen großen
anteil hat haben sie nun das erreichen
der ko runde in der eigenen hand
moral war sagenhaft gut und auch das
spiel nach vorne wir haben wirklich auf
die gegner so viel druck ausgeübt dass
sie eigentlich dem nicht standhalten
konnten wir haben heute was was leiden
schafft das team spirit angeht eine
geile leistung gezeigt darauf können wir
aufbauen wir viel richtig gemacht haben
gegen einen sehr guten gegner heute
agiert und das mit bravour gemeistert
dank robin goossens an drei toren
beteiligt findet das team zur em form es
gab noch zwei weitere em spiele heute in
der gruppe f wenn der auch deutschland
ist trennten sich ungarn und frankreich
in budapest 1 zu 1 unentschieden und in
sevilla trennten sie spanien und polen
ebenfalls 1 zu 1 unentschieden
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
lottozahlen 11 19 21 29 35 36 superzahl
2 und weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie
auf lotto punkt zdf de und im zdf text
auf seite 55 6 es gibt unwetterwarnungen
des deutschen wetterdienstes vor
schweren gewittern mit heftigem
starkregen und tage teils auch mit
orkanböen und zwar für teile von
nordrhein-westfalen rheinland-pfalz und
baden-württemberg und werde aussichten
für morgen zwischen den alpen und den
küsten teils heftige gewitter mit
starkregen hagel und sturmböen
nur im osten länger sonnig erneut
schwül-warm bei 25 bis 36 grad
die weiteren aussichten in den nächsten
tagen bleibt die unwettergefahr teils
noch wo zwischendurch gibt es auch immer
wieder freundliche abschnitte dazu wird
es langsam wieder etwas kühler
das war es von uns bis morgen wenn sie
mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]